لطالما سالت نفسي اين ساكون بعد خمس سنوات
لكني لم احلم يوما ان اصل الى ما وصلت
اليه اليوم ولو بعد عشرين سنه قادمه فاطمه
ناصر طبيبه من الحسكه ماجستير في اداره
الاعمال
بدات الحكايه منذ خمس سنوات بالضبط حين
قررت انا وزوجي وطفلي الصغير الانتقال
للعيش في اللاذقيه بغيت استكمال زوجي
دراساته في جامعه
سافرنا باحلام عريضه كان اخرها باننا بعد
عام سنملك سياره الخاصه لننتقل الى
الكورنيش ونستمتع بمشهد البحر لم نكن نعلم
باننا سنعود 0 اليدين معدمين فقط
بدات رحله البحث عن عمل كانت الرحله شاقه
اكثر من المتوقع سته اشهر من البحث المضني
دون جدوى كان اخرها بانني وجدت فرصه للعمل
في اكبر المراكز في اللاذقيه لاكتشف لان
الراتب لطبيب بدوام صباح ومسائل لا يتجاوز
الخمس وستين الف ليله هذا المبلغ في ذلك
الوقت لا يكفي حليب ابنه الذي لا يتجاوز
سته اشهر انا ذاك وللحليب قصه اخرى
كانت اللاذقيه تعاني من انقطاع شبه تام في
الحليب كنا نتقاسم الحي انا وزوجي في رحله
البحر عن معلمه حليب لا تكفي لاياما
حتى بحثت عن عمل ثاني وثالث ورابع دون
اجدها
في ذلك الوقت بدات بدراسه ماجستير اداره
الاعمال كنوع من انواع الهروب من الواقع
وتحقيق اللحم القديم تعرضت لبعض
الانتقادات عما هي علاقه اداره الاعمال
بطل ليجد بعدها فرصه اداريه في احد
الشركات التجميليه
فاعتقدت بانني قد وجدت فرصه الاحلام
لمقابله شرحها للمدير اساسيات العمل كنت
اولا الواصلين في اليوم التالي
لاكتشف بان العمل هو عكس ما شرح لي تماما
وان علي عن احمل حقيبه من المنتجات
التجاريه وادور بها بين المنازل واقنع
الناس بالشراء
قضيه يومي اقنع النساء بشراء مسكن زيت
الثعبان لتقويه الرموش حقيقه الشعر بخيله
كبيره قضيت الطريق الواصله للمنزل في
البكاء او ردد في نفسي هل هذا هو المكان
الذي كنت احلم ان اكون فيه قبل خمس سنوات
بدات وحدها بمشروع لتجاره الالبسه بين
الحسكه واللاذقيه انشات حسابا وهميا على
الفيسبوك ومجموعه واتساب بدات بها بنشر
البضائع تباعا فشل المشروع فشل ذريعا بسبب
مشاكل الشحن بين منطقتين والصليبيه الحال
انني انشات حساب على احد مواقع العمل الحر
هذه المواقع تتطلب ان تقدم خدمه مقابل
خمسه دولار بدات بتعلم الفوتوشوب على امل
انا ابدا العمل
فاكتشفت ان
يتطلب مني الكثير من الوقت الكثير من
الوقت
سنه كامله من الخذلان سنه كامله من الخيبه
سنه كامله الانكسارات مصروف عائله بدون اي
وارد قررت ان اعود الى الحسد
زوجه بعيده عن زوجها طفل بعيد عن ابيه
حرفيا كنا قد عدنا الى نقطه الصفر
بدات بالتقدم الى اي فرصه عمل تواجه في
المحافظه كان اخرها بانني تقدمت الى مدخل
البيانات في احد الجمعيات المح
ليه وقتل بالطبع طبيبه ماجستير في اداره
الاعمال اغلقت كل الابواب في وجهي
تقترح علي احد الزملاء ان افتتح عياده عن
طريق الاقساط الشهريه هذا الخيار لم يكن
واردا فلم املك ما يمكنني من هذه الخطوه
قياده عن طريق الاقساط قال لك حوالي 4000
دولار وانا الامريكي من واحدا حتى
العياده عن طريق الاقساط اي ان نصف المبلغ
ويدفع الباقي عن طريق الاقسام لا اعلم اي
قوه جاءتني لاذهب واقابل مدير الشركه
واطلب منه عياده بدون اي قصد شهري
ولان من ادمن قرع الباب وشرك ان يفتح له
جاءت الموافقه والذي كانت البدايه لكل ما
تقدم
بدات بعياده بسيطه وامكانيات بسيطه واحلام
كبيره شرعت بتطبيق مبادئ الاداره والاداره
الماليه والتسويق المجموعات انشات صفحه
على الفيسبوك وبدات بنشر الحالات تباعا
بعد عام انتقلت الى مكان اكبر وبدات
الاحلام
لم تكن المهمه
سهله ان تكوني المديره والزوجه والطبيبه
والام في الوقت ذاته في العام الذي تلاه
اعلنت عن افتتاح اول واكبر مركز طبي في
المحافظه
بكادر يتجاوز الثلاثين شخص وفريق اعلامي
مسؤول عن اداره الصفحه نشر المحتوى كتابه
كتابه المنشورات نشر دستوريات تباعا
عياده تتالف من عياده طب اسنان باطباء من
مختلف الاختصاصات عياده للتغذيه عياده
لليزر تحوي احدث اصدارات الليزر في
المنطقه عياده للتغذيه والعلاج الفيزيائي
والصيدليه تحوي منتجات من اشهر الماركات
العالميه
لم تكن المهمه سهله بالطبع ولم يكن ذلك
وليد الصدفه بل كان نتاج عام مثمر وايام
شاقه
رسالتي للشباب الذي اخذ من الازمه شماعه
على التقاعس
ان المستحيل مجرد كلمه وشكرا
[تصفيق]